I don't disavow my biological ancestors
for the same reason that we should not
avow our political ancestors men such as
Christopher Columbus the founding
fathers all the Great Men Who Built our
nation namely because without them we
would not be here we stand on the
shoulders of giants and the stupid ones
Among Us think that they are flying why
did our ancestors literal and political
settle this land why did they colonize
this farflung place the decolonization
activists will tell you they did so for
material plunder as usual these liberal
accusations are in fact confessions
having adopted the fashionable
materialism of modernity these leftists
cannot even imagine that one might be
motivated by higher ideals but in the
case of the great men of history that we
are discussing Columbus the pilgrims The
Fanny fathers they were and the proof of
that is that none of them got
particularly Rich for their troubles